washington-dc man in this place if you
haven't been to washington d.c it is a
it's like monopoly but it's Marvin
gardens I mean everywhere you turn is it
is Marvin gardens they have you know
every building looks like a library I
mean you go you know I'm at a Subway
sandwich and next thing you know they
put in periodicals on my um on my
six-inch suite it's a wild place and I
want to thank everybody that came out
you know as I usually do today's episode
is brought to you by gray block pizza
gray block pizza 18:11 Pico Boulevard in
Los Angeles in gray block it's that
pizza that you need also today's episode
is brought to you by laughable laughable
is the premiere podcast app iPhone users
are you using laughable yet you might
have heard Bert Kreischer and Ari
Shaffir and some other comics recommend
it and now I want to recommend it to you
for all of your podcast listening a
friend of mine Ned works over there and
they run a good company and a caring
company and here's why they're special
if you go to laughable you get their app
you go to my laughable profile and
you'll find all the podcasts I've ever
been on as a host or a guest you know or
somebody dropping in hell if I did a
drive-by shooting at a podcast you'll be
able to you know at least hear me drop
by in the distance so I've had 58 guest
episodes I guess
Wow I don't even really realize that
once you subscribe to me on laughable
anytime a podcast comes out that I'm on
even as a guest they will let you know
you can subscribe to all your other
favorite comics as well you can
subscribe to podcast series just like
you do on a regular podcast app
laughable 'he's got everything i will
put a swipe up in my story so you can
get ahold of those guys over
there there's laughable so give it a try
it's 100% free it's free go to the App
Store in search laughable la ugh a B le
Android users it's coming in 2019
alright let's get into the episode
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome guys and that is Christmas
greetings from America by Friedrich
Thalberg and Thalberg I think is um hell
who knows what that is man that's a
that's something else that's that's a
real Reacher
but greetings from America is
appropriate today it's Christmas on its
way you know Santa you can you hear you
can hear him in the distance putting his
boots on you know using that fingernail
file on his foot
you ever get that deal man I don't know
if you've ever been a man or if you are
a man but I remember getting you know my
mom had finger nail files because she
had fingernails and sometimes when I was
young I would get her file you know I
you know that was the thing I guess when
I was young like if I snuck in to my
parents room it was just my mother so I
got all you know I'm in there I got high
heels on you know I'm running you know
I'm putting I would get the file
sometime a fingernail file and I start
filing and you filed I filed some of my
said I was sharpen my elbows you know I
was young I didn't know what to do
you know I file anything I remember
trying to file my ears down and making
my ears all scabbed up on the sides
because I didn't like you know the size
of my ears when I was young and then
older when I became older which I have
and I'm trying and I'm still doing you
know constantly and because age you know
age is a religion that we all kind of we
all are subscribing to but as I've
gotten older I'll get that fingernail
file sometime and there's an age for a
man when the sides of your feet start
getting hard and kind of crisping out
it's almost like your skin gets kind of
like erect on the edges of your feet and
it wants to kind of [ __ ] the sides of
the war of the world but and you got to
get a file and you got to go to town on
that and I remember the first time ever
did that and you create a cloud of just
dust it looks like salt and I don't
think you should taste any attack
because that's not salt your body
doesn't make salt you know that's just
debt that's dust I mean that's dead body
that's coming off of you and and I I
remember getting you know I probably I
don't remember the first time I did it
but I got that fingernail file and
started just creating that dead body
cloud around you you just and your feet
is just smoking you know that [ __ ] hits
the air and it can get thick when you
you know you you you know you chiseling
off that crisp when you if you got that
foot crisp you know you chiseling that
thing off and if you smoke sometimes
it'll be yellow on the edge if you smoke
a lot or if you take your shoes off and
let your grandparents smoke by your feet
then it'll be real yellow sometimes on
the edge that crisp and you got to
chisel that off but oh I don't know what
we're talking about but have I ever I
don't think I have how are you where are
you today Thanksgivings over you feel in
the you know the holiday spirit are you
starting to feel it you know it gets
different the holidays as we get older
you know at a certain point it's not
about it's interesting it's not about
getting anymore you know it's of it
really is about given you know even at
Christmas you see this time of year you
just want people to be joyous and you
want people to be happy I feel like you
know I do anyway and I just want to try
and contribute to that but I mean I am
in Los Angeles and I know I'm in
Washington DC sorry and if you can sit
there if you can see this
video on the YouTube this [ __ ] look like
a Isis video this this look like a plea
for help this video the setup we have
but I'm grateful to re Manas who is a
featuring for me this weekend in in
Washington DC and uh and that he helped
me set this up you know he he offered it
was late you know it's we just got back
from the comedy club from the Sunday
show it's ten o'clock and we set in this
this up in the hotel room and we got to
be we're leaving for the airport at 5:00
a.m.
we still going to edit this bad cat but
he offered to help you know and it made
me feel good man because uh that's you
know it's just that time of year and I
want to do that and I want to that
s'what I want to do I want to just you
know I want to keep my eyes open and try
and be part of some solutions and just
see what I could do but happy Holidays
to you whatever holiday you celebrate
you know I love Christmas you know they
got a little baby in the desert and you
got to think about that man I mean you
got to think how much love was in the
air if three old men went to visit a
baby in the desert and Chris Hanson
wasn't there I mean now you know there
was a different type of love in the air
at that time these days you know one old
dude shows up to a you know a trap house
in Florida or something and next thing
you know you got federal agents and
everybody so it was just a different
time there was a lot of love in the air
and I think people loved more without
you know without any of the dark arts
kind of seeping in I think most of the
the love that was in people at those
times was above the waist and now some
of our love it's like an hourglass and
it's kind of you know that's that the
sand is starting to you know kind of uh
just
it's it's the same to start a new file
you know float down towards our garage
you know it so I don't want to say it
too loud because it's holidays but
crotch but yeah man we were in DC what
did I do I want to thank everybody that
came out you know how I do it
it was nice man we flew out and do we
got first class on the airplane and
first class man look I don't get it all
the time you know I started to get it
more often and it's new to me you know
some people probably always get first
class you know ariana grande Chris
D'Elia you know he got first class he
rich I don't know if you know Chris
D'Elia or not or Delia but I heard a
rumor that he was at a coffee shop and
the table was uneven that he was sitting
at and he took $600 and put it under the
little edge of the you know the bottom
corner of the table to fix it and left
it there when he left so that's wild and
he has all kind of bathtubs in his house
and you know somebody said he has a
bathtub that has like a little you know
like a little um you know a like a uh
all different type of soaps like a
little soap buffet on the edge of it and
that's different man I'm used to you
know you get one kind of soap you get
you you go in there and it's like Oh
what kind of soap do we have we got
[ __ ] soap that's it the only kind
they ever had was just soap and Chris
D'Elia
darling probably has blueberries soap
you know crystal you know soap that
looks like so but it's just crystal and
it's not even really soap it's actual
crystal and you know coconut soap or you
know different type of stuff menthol
different type of varieties because they
he's like that but that's what I felt
like when I got in first class man we
got up there
and re man as he got bumped up wit me
that lucky little [ __ ] Tron he got
bumped up so we're in we're in and man
they had a lay down bed dude
first of all if I'm laying down you know
what I'm saying I'm putting one of my
hands in my pants most of the time and
that I don't and that's not a pervert
thing that's just uh you know when I lay
down I like to one of my hands
automatically kind of goes into my pants
I don't know what that is it must be for
safety or something because a long time
ago I don't know if you guys have ever
read like a lot of history books or the
Bible or you know different type of
Muslim Muslim literature or slim
literature some people say instead of
Muslim a lot of people say slim if
you've ever read a lot of slim
literature or nature books or even just
seeing you know a lot of dioramas and
stuff from when we were children you
know that people were naked a long time
ago clothes have only been around for
probably two hundred forty years so
after that before that man it was
straight up you know it was dick city
you know no offense or you know it was
also you know vagina Stan but it was
also dick city of his boat and and so
people were a lot more natural then but
it was also very dangerous
because you had to keep your crotch
clean because the animal could smell
your body you know one of the top four
places your body has a scent as in is
your crotch and so I you know an animal
would notice that and so you have to
really cover your junk you know to
really because you don't want to add you
don't want to ant eater coming at night
you know when siphoning your crops right
off your body I mean it's it's not
something that people want
so you have to take care of yourself and
usually that's why I think you know it
since there's something innate in us
there's something medieval and limbic in
our brains when we say go to bed at
night you cover your you cover your
crotch with your hand because look this
is my livelihood this is where I'm
carrying the future of my lineage I'm
not out here trying to [ __ ] you know
feed a hyena in the middle of the night
who's got a strong nose on him and next
thing you know he's not he's not on my
Siraj he's you know he's just trying to
have a snack while I'm trying to rest
come on
so that's nature of some of that to
cover your body while you sleep but it
was nice the first class man it was
really really really nice and and yeah
and you can lay down and they at one
point they brought a warm cookie
they had a lady her name I think I
couldn't even pronounce it she was like
every ethnicity share Baca or something
or sure you know Thumbelina I don't know
what her name was
pretty beautiful I think I don't know
it's dark up there in first class you
get in a coach in middle could they but
you know they floated floodlights on you
they interrogating back there that's
just witness protection up there in the
front
it's witness protection but it was nice
man so that was you know look I felt
lucky that I got bumped up I didn't pay
for that I got bumped into that but
people came out to the shows in DC we
flew in on Friday and went straight to
the shows pretty much and I don't know
if you guys came out to the comedy club
but I thought it was you know it looked
like about the last stop on the
Underground Railroad they had you know I
thought at first I'm like damn this a
damn Trap House
you know any minute the feds gonna bust
through the windows and they're gonna be
searching you know a couple people's
offices for our
you know for cocaine and stuff like that
the lot at all it at pills not weed me
dude remember they had that one kid who
used to hide weed in his own in his
sphincter what an idiot
I'd rather have gone to jail for we
didn't have to pull a couple giants out
of my bottom come on man you better get
with the Lord bro like I don't know look
if you got you know six or seven kilos
or some grams or you know some you know
rare doubloons or you know gold bullion
yeah hotter than your [ __ ] little you
know in that warm little Locker and that
a little Hurt Locker but you got you
know you're running around with you know
six buds of that purple rain or whatever
it's called you know emphysema black or
whatever this you know these different
strands are called they always had that
one dude the cops showed up and you you
guys that you have anything on you
everybody it's like now I don't have
nothing and then one of your boys in the
backseat talk to another boy who's kind
of been maybe questioning his sexuality
and a you know uploading a couple of
nugs into his bottom different times man
but yeah the show you know and at first
I was like this place is wild it seemed
like a fire hazard
it seemed yeah I was like this thing
like a trap how you know this seemed
like it's on the Underground Railroad
and nobody would even get off you know
even runaway servants and stuff would be
like we'll go back you know but it grew
on me over time and you know what it and
you know why was because um you guys
came out and there was this a lot of joy
a lot of joy man some big hugs
there's always some dude comes out talks
about you know sobriety he's all coked
out of his mind he's like you've helped
me but then there's like other people
who come out and you know you just
really feel that they you know just have
a lot of joy in their lives and they're
trying to make more joy and that
inspires me and yeah by the beginning
it's funny because whenever I relate
with other people you know I get less
judgmental because the first day I'm at
the club and I'm thinking man this they
had all kind of siding falling out
insulation one do right you know put a
little bit of insulation his bookbag and
[ __ ] quit work like damn they doing
whatever they had a security guard he
was sitting down most of the time and he
was he kept asking me if his shirt fit
okay I said he was you're an insecurity
guard
he asked me if he felt like his ears
were a decent size for his body
[ __ ] let's just chill papa and
at first I'm there and I'm judgmental
you know when they had um you know they
just had a it was an eclectic group but
we had you know we made the most of it
and by the end of the weekend I was
having fun and it's uh you know I find
whenever I just relate to others and
don't think about other you know
whenever I just communicate with people
a lot of my judgment goes away and I was
finding some joy but so there's some
wild cats that came out in DC this crazy
Mexican chick named Bobo what Bobo do
you how are you gonna be named after a
children's injury who named your dad
ally who's out you got a cousin named
Aoi on his mobile now we so that was
unique
who else came out we had a gentleman it
was his birthday somebody made me a rat
King belt was pretty cool
your boy uh Copernicus somebody gave me
a nice gift I haven't opened it up yet
today's podcast is brought to you by M
in ml case minimal case it's the world's
thinnest phone case that's right it's
just point zero one inches thick man
that is so thin
someone said new iPhone X's XR are in
stock and new pixel threes are in stock
as well you can get cases for those
phones showcase the beauty of your phone
imagine your phone wants to go out to a
nice dinner you know at roofs crisps or
um you know Shanghai diamond or
something fancy Chinese place wouldn't
you want it to be in a sexy dress well
this is just that the M in ml case
minimal case it's I mean it's super thin
you're gonna be shocked out then it is
okay it is so thin now this isn't
something if you're gonna take your
phone off road and you're gonna throw
your phone at your cousin you know
because he's been drinking and he stole
something and that's between y'all don't
do that in this case but you have a
hundred percent money-back guarantee if
you were unhappy for whatever reason
they'll refund the purchase of the case
no need to even send the case back so
you can our tpw listeners get 20% off by
visited by visiting em in m/l case comm
that's M in ml CAS e calm and use promo
code Theo
that's promo code Theo for 20% off @m in
ml case CAS e.com it is thin Mattamy
you're gonna be you're gonna be shocked
shocked you know what was crazy this
week in Washington DC people came out
and had that Ridge that front pocket
carry and we live in a dangerous time
sometimes these days actually I think we
always have actually I think it was way
more dangerous maybe 100 years ago when
people were you know fighting the plague
and shooting each other you know
you know and stealing each other's gold
but also right now you may need
protection
well protect yourself protect your money
with the ridge wallet this thing can
stop a bullet dude what kind of bullet I
wouldn't try and find out
but the ridge wallet is that front
pocket carry a lot of people are still
carrying stuff on their back in there
but you know what are you a drug mule no
take care of yourself get that Ridge
wallet that front pocket carry carries
your credit cards carries your ID small
concise put it up front bang bang bang
bang get that hitter you can go to Ridge
wallet calm slash Theo and use promo
code th EO at checkout for 10% off
that's code th EO for 10% off at Ridge
wallet dot-com slash Theo thank you for
supporting the podcast and now back to
the episode and and some people came out
and just talked about sobriety and stuff
like that or you know people just all
types you know a lot of loving people
one guy came out and uh you know just
really wanted to express to me that he
was grateful for the podcast being a
place to hang out man that made me feel
good you know it made me feel good I'll
tell you this man oh yeah the holidays
are here it's gonna come quick so you
have to you have to plan ahead right now
to get some gift for people and
sometimes I made a nice gift for
somebody these days especially can even
be just a nice video that maybe you have
a friend edit you know maybe your
grandparents don't get to see their kids
you know the grandkids or something a
lot maybe making them something special
that's a nice free gift you can make or
something cute could be what if you
dressed your kids up like the
grandparents you know give your kid a
little cane or something and maybe um
you know a couple you know a little sack
up
and maybe a little like a shirt like a
little butler outfit or something
there's some spectacles and then you
send your kid out that could be kind of
neat I don't know but yeah that could be
a fun video you can make for senior
citizens what else is going on made it
into DC we made it through the Sunday
night it's Sunday night here I'm still
in Washington DC we went to the portrait
museum that was enjoyable and they have
all the UH portraits of all the
presidents in there I learned that they
they have Secret Service like security
for president Trump but then he also has
his own security so there's like double
security running around all the time
which i think is just kind of wild and
crazy and just maybe it's just exemplary
of our times you know that nobody feels
like they can trust each other at and
these are these government levels and I
think some of that's good I think a
shake up is good man you know change is
always kind of tricky but it's really
the thing that's you know can you know
can kind of show us new opportunities I
believe that what else man I'm just
grateful to be in America and really
seeing like when you come here and you
see all the people that are like
tourists and just you know and people
just like crying at different monuments
and expressing their you know their
gratitude or sharing a story with their
kids about something battle that their
father was in or it's beautiful man it
makes you think about you know how far
this country has come and what it is and
it makes you think about kind of your
place in it anyway it was for me you
know is making me think about
just making me think about about being
an American and just grateful that I can
you know I got a holiday season coming
up where I can you know make a lot of
joy and that's good [ __ ] right joy is
probably one of the top 60 or 70 things
but yeah a lot of good people came out
thank you so much for coming out in DC
you know and that's the the club I
thought it was haunted they had you know
people in the bathroom saying Candyman
six times and [ __ ] people disappear some
guy said his wife left him I mean it
really the place had a wild vibe to it
and it was slang you know people
slinging tater tots and doing that and
stuff die little peppers that have been
you know infiltrated with cheese and
[ __ ] they're all type of stuff you know
they had they had a tray of meats in the
back um and it was it was something man
it was something else and a lot of good
people came out so thank you very much
somebody else don't want to tell you
guys oh I'll tell you guys this we do
have some new shows coming up that are
that are on sale now and the House of
Blues show in New Orleans has sold out
that's what I heard and that's the day
after Christmas so I'm excited about
that I was texting uh with Dustin
Poirier from Louisiana and there's a
rumor that he's gonna be Fighting Irish
guy alcohol sells alcohol still fights
though what's his name
Colin McGill uh Cullum McGill no Connor
McGrane Conor McGregor so they're gonna
fight so that's pretty exciting someone
kind of keep my eyes open for the date
on that and cheer on a little bit of
Louisiana Chris Hansen is on this week
dude he came in the studio Chris Hansen
and when you get around him he is Chris
Hansen you forget like [ __ ] I wonder
what it's like to be Chris Hansen and
then you're around
you're like [ __ ] man it makes you feel
good you know that you're on the
up-and-up in some of those areas it
makes you feel good that you don't live
in countries where you know children are
meeting adults you know and stuff like
that and and vice versa and uh dude it
was an experience you know what
sometimes I like interview and I just
sometimes I don't know if I know of that
much about it about being an interviewer
you know I don't know if I know that
much about it but a lot going on this
week man I wanted to talk about I wanted
to talk about sobriety and stuff like
that but I just have a little bit of a
headache and I wanted to be able to drop
more into it a little bit and I still
may let me see how I'm feeling just in
just a few minutes but I want to tell
you about these tour dates coming up the
House of Blues in New Orleans
Omaha funnybone January 11th and 12th
Irvine improv January 18th through the
20th I will be back at Addison improv
I'll be there this Thursday but then
I'll also be there January 25th and 26th
in Addison Texas Columbus funnybone
Columbus Ohio February 8th and 9th and
then the Houston improv February 22nd
and 23rd so those are shows that you can
you can get on onboard and I'm excited
to be going to some new places oh man
what a week what else happened dude this
city is diverse Wow every I don't even
know I don't know I don't know what's
going on and it's like damn like the
library you ever been in the library
dude libraries [ __ ] diverse is [ __ ]
and uh yeah it just feels what does it
feel like here it feels like house of
cards like you're walking around in
house of cards like ever like people
thinking they got secret information you
see like a dark cargo buying you're like
who is that
you know what diplomat some shady [ __ ]
who is it
you know Martha's Vineyard who is it
Martha Stewart I mean so pretty
interesting I guess Oh what else man
I'll tell you this I'll tell you this I
am here I'll tell you how I got sober
man let's just we'll get into it you
know I've been talking about it for
awhile there's never really like a right
time to talk about that sort of thing
but I do want to be able to share it
with you guys
because sometimes people ask about it
and wonder what's up and then you know
I'll just tell you how I got into that
so you know I was born I was born my
father was an old man my dad was 70
years old when I was born
and my mother was 32 and and they had
four children and you know when I was
born I think there was some shame or
uncertainty by my parents they had me
call my dad by his first name instead of
calling him dad
because I guess maybe they'd gotten a
lot of you know strange looks from
people or or judgment and maybe they
felt like that was a way that wouldn't
make it easier on them and maybe on us
too but my father was very old when I
was born
and as I started to get to know him I
was just kind of scared because you know
he was a senior citizen and and he was
just kept getting older like as I was
getting older he was getting older and I
remember you know when he wouldn't go on
and walk in a church one time and I had
to like walk him like make sure he was
okay where he was stepping and uh you
know just what the concrete was like and
so he didn't you know trip and that sort
of thing
and so it just made me I think hyper
aware when I was really young I was very
aware and my mother worked a lot and
and she wasn't really connected to me
you know she just worked a lot and she
had to work you know she had four
children and my parents got divorced and
we lived in like a and we moved to like
a poor area and and I guess I just
started to feel like I shamed you know I
felt ashamed of the fact that my family
was poor I felt ashamed that my dad was
old and couldn't you know couldn't be
like as much a part of my life in a lot
of ways because physically it was
hampering to him and then because my
parents were separated in and then he
wasn't around and you know I and I
started making up stories and I would
tell people stories to make my life
different than it was you know I would
tell people you know I would take the
school bus sometimes to a different
neighborhood and get dropped off and
then walk because I didn't want people
to see where I lived and I would started
riding my bike to school I'd ride my
bike maybe five miles to school when I
was in middle school you know and that's
fifth grade and maybe that's not wild
but at the time it didn't feel wild to
me you know it felt like this is what I
need to do to feel okay so you know my
peers won't judge me or and they may not
even have been judging me I just felt I
don't know I guess I just felt judged I
felt less than I felt I don't know
honestly I didn't know sometimes I
didn't really feel anything but I knew
that if I showed up at school on the
poor bus then people knew I was poor and
and
and I already felt bad enough because
nobody was telling me in my world like
one of my parents that I could feel okay
about myself you know I didn't have my
you know there wasn't a father around
and this isn't a sob story I'm trying to
tell you guys I'm trying to tell you how
I ended up getting into a Alcoholics
Anonymous for me I'm not saying you need
to do this I don't know your life I
don't know your world if you were doing
an Eightball right now and listen to
this bra and eaten
you know and eating somebody's butt you
matter whatever do your thing
I'm not judging you at all man I wish I
was right there with you one day I may
be back but for now this is where I am
so I just felt you know I just felt less
than I felt I didn't I didn't know
anything about myself how to feel good
about myself so the only way I knew to
feel good was if I could make you like
me I needed like I needed you I only
decided how I felt based on how you felt
about me and it went from moment to
moment and so I was a storyteller
because I wanted my life to be different
to other people and so I told stories
and and also I liked to make him people
laugh because I knew that if they were
laughing then they they they were ok
with me you know that it they couldn't
be hating me and laugh and at the same
time my sister I had a younger sister
who was very ill she was born with a
rare liver disease and she needed a
liver transplant upon her birth and so
when my mother did have free time a lot
of time my sister got the affection
because she was ill and she got a lot
more love and affection than my brothers
and sister my other brother and my other
sister did I felt like anyhow I was you
know growing up and one thing I really
loved was summertime I would go to YMCA
summer camp and as summer camp things
weren't as clicky everybody was on the
same page
it was it was a group of kids in the
summer that just wanted to have fun we
got to do fun stuff we all you know rode
on a bus together from the camp to go to
field trips and I just loved that and
you know our and and and people didn't
is just this wasn't as judgmental you
know my mom would drop us off there and
we'd stay there and go to summer camp
and we weren't it just felt like less
judgment and one day I was um I was
walking in my neighborhood and one of
the counselors from my summer camp drove
down the street he was happy to be
driving through my neighborhood and he
saw me in this neighborhood and there
was a you know a neighborhood was poor
man it was you know I think it was the
poorest white neighborhood that was
around us I felt like and that and then
when I saw him at summer camp he was
joking with some of the other counselors
he was making fun of where I lived he
was making fun of you know he was making
fun of the place he saw me run out of
the apartment I ran out of and and it
just at that point like a lot of
something inside of me just really kind
of died something you know like here was
this one place where I really felt kind
of okay and now that place didn't feel
ok to me anymore
so you know so high school went on and
God gave me some good gifts and I was a
storyteller and you know I was always
concerned though like you know I always
needed to be around more people or
everything was always started to be you
know we need to change this we need to
do that I'd go to a party and then I'd
have to go to another part like where's
the party where we're at the party
something never felt kind of okay I just
never felt okay I always felt like I was
trying to make things okay and things
weren't bad I had some great times I was
fun I was having fun
but on the inside I was I didn't know
who I was at all I didn't have any
beliefs I didn't have any real values
and how I felt about me was based upon
how you felt about me and when I was 14
I got emancipated you know I couldn't
live at my family's home anymore my
brother had moved away to live with my
grandparents and he and I weren't close
and and I and after he'd moved away you
know I bet I'd spent a lot of time in
our room by myself and it made me I
think real sad because my brother's bed
was in there and my bed was in there you
know in every kind of like year every
six months he would say you know and my
mom would say he might come back and
live with us again and he didn't come
back you know and I don't fault him for
it or anything he you know he had his
own walk with our environment and he
needed to find a place for him to be
well and and he's gotten very well over
the years and uh and anyhow so but it
all like I was just in this room and I
wanted things to be different and I was
a scared kid you know and this before I
moved out of my mother's home and I just
remember being really scared I wanted to
I remember being at night they uh you
know our neighborhood was scary and it
was just we grew up like it was you know
kind of poor white and poor black was
like right over from us and it was just
you know it was scary when people get
real impoverished like things get scary
and I was just scared and at night I
would do it I was a scared kid I
remember like I would wet the bed all
the time you know and I remember I
remember there was a mom at one time
when I was young I heard that if I
animal had urinated somewhere that other
animals couldn't come get that animal
and so I remember at that point
sometimes I would urinate off my bed
around my bed in a big circle at night
so that things couldn't come get me
you know I was just creating this crazy
like world inside of me there was a lot
of fear and there was a lot of
uncertainty and there was not a lot of
systems inside of myself to make myself
feel okay and my mother and I were just
disconnected man you know she gave us
birthdays and she gave us holidays but
she had to work hard and I think that
she you know I don't know I don't know
if she had the tools really to make me
feel loved you know so anyhow I got
emancipated at 14 I ended up living with
the family for the first time I had my
own room and I had peace I had some
peace in my life I mean just like
moments where I just felt like I could
relax a little bit but this but this
thing inside of me of not feeling okay
was still very much there and you know I
developed issues with women where you
know I had a really tough time relating
to women and and trusting women and
feeling okay and and really being able
to commit to relationships and at some
point you know life went on things were
going okay but I started using at some
point cocaine a little bit and I liked
cocaine because I would get it and do it
by myself at home at night and I would
just do it and it just made me feel good
and enough to be around other people and
I don't know it just made me feel
something it made me feel something for
so long inside of myself I'd had so many
years really of creating my own feelings
on the outside of me but not really
having them inside of me you know like I
just didn't have feeling and inside like
I just if I wanted to feel something I
had to think it up and then act it out
and display it as I'd seen it displayed
in like television or movies are from
others but the inside of me there wasn't
a lot going on
so anyhow like the you know and I wasn't
getting crazy in the drugs or anything
like that but I had one night where I
ended up in a taxicab and a woman said
something to me kind of rejected me in
like a mean way and I hadn't done
anything wild I just you know had you
know I you know express some interest
and she expressed interest and then I
returned the expression and then she was
mean to me and she didn't reject the
rejection is fine but she was mean to me
also and next thing you know the taxi
driver dropped her off we were in a taxi
and next thing you know I end up with a
taxi driver
four hours later me and him are doing
cocaine together and and I'm driving the
taxi and he's in the back he's in the
back with an escort he bought me an
escort I don't want no escort you know
luigi that was the guy's name and we're
in North Harlem and I'm driving a taxi
and the meter is still running I'm still
paying for that taxi and uh and that
morning I was in New York because I had
to be on I was in New York I had to be
on a big radio show called the Opium Jim
Norton radio show and they had like a
million listeners and it was a huge
opportunity and if you'd asked me the
night before hey man are you gonna stay
up all night partying before you go into
the radio I'd have said no way I would
never do that and then here I was in
this moment and it's 5:00 a.m. I got to
go to the radio you know I mean I got to
my hotel after driving taxi and then
paying for it dude just blown out of my
mind dude I couldn't feel my face with
either hand at first I thought something
was wrong on my hands but then I
realized something on my face and
and I get to the radio station get it
took three showers in ten minutes before
I went there so you know you want some
really you know some belt dust if you're
taking three showers in ten minutes
and drying off between each one and
that's cocaine papa and I get to the
radio station and the other guests and I
can't even talk and and the other guest
for the day was Darryl Strawberry who
was a Hall of Fame baseball player and
he's even look him up and he's one of
the greatest baseball players ever but
he his career was really altered by
cocaine and here he was I was on the
radio with him I had it collected his
cards when I was young and I couldn't
even talk the main gift that God had
given me was my voice and I couldn't
even use it because I've been up all
night just using drugs to feel good
somehow or using drugs to feel anything
and and that was crazy because I'd
always thought in my head Oh Darryl
Strawberry you think you thought about
him and you thought oh he's on drugs
he's this and that he ruined his life
but then here he was in front of he was
13 years sober he was eloquent
successful and I mean he was a Dan King
sitting in front of me and at one moment
that's where some things lined up in my
life that's where some things lined up
in my mind and said oh hey look here you
are with this gift you think you have
that you can communicate you can't even
talk because you [ __ ] up brah because
you've been out driving taxi and here
you are with somebody who you thought or
had judged as being [ __ ] up and here
he is a king and it just lined things up
in a perfect moment where I just had
this moment of like oh I need to
something needs to change for me and the
next day I was back in Los Angeles I was
telling that same story to someone and
they said hey man I go to these meetings
you know I go to meetings and so then I
went to some AAA meetings
and you know and for the first time in
my life I sat down and listened to
people tell stories which were my
favorite thing to hear my whole life
I've been loving stories man I love your
story you know whatever your story is I
love it man I'll because all my life
when I was young I just wanted a
different story I wanted a different
story whether I had to tell it or try
and live yours whether I had to get
emancipated and come live at your house
or this house or that house I just
wanted a different story man I wanted to
be I wanted to be in a family and I
wanted to feel loved you know you know I
just really I mean I think and I didn't
even know it I didn't know how much I
wanted to how much I wanted to be loved
man I just didn't even know it and once
I got into these rooms I could you had
to sit there you had to be quiet and you
had to hear other people and people
started talking and telling their
stories and for the first time in my
life they were telling emotional like
tales of that were exciting and [ __ ]
dope and like deep and real and I
connected that with that I loved it
you know I loved it in that and so I
just kept going I just kept going and
next thing you know I was like next
thing you know I had a couple nights in
a row a couple weeks in a row or months
in a row while I was spending time with
other people and I was meeting people
and I and like suddenly Los Angeles
became like this place that I'd always
kind of hated and judged it became a
little bit I still don't like that place
people are out of their [ __ ] minds
out there wants a disconnected kook's
judging most of the of the rest of
America but it also made me it gave me a
place to kind of it just gave me friends
it gave me people and because I know
those people had had struggles I knew
that they'd felt some of the same ways
that I felt inside
I couldn't judge those people you know
even though sometimes I wanted to you
know you never do come in and like you
know and you know he'd lost his family
or he you know he he lost his kids and
been taken away by the courts and he's
drinking or a woman who addicted to
heroin and she you know hadn't seen and
finally they're getting their lives back
together and you just you know they say
like listen for the similarities not the
differences and I always want him in my
life sometimes I'd always wanted to
listen for differences because
differences gave me an ability to
separate me from other people and if I'm
just me by myself then I know that I'm
I'm okay because it's the only thing
I've ever known the only way I've ever
been okay really is by being by myself I
don't know an okay where I'm attached to
others you know where I trust others had
like a place deeper than my own feelings
a place that I don't really know but for
the first time in these rooms I could do
it you know for the first time in these
rooms like I started like man I had love
for people that didn't even know and
then in moments and still this stuff
kind of comes slow but I start to have
love for myself you know and the hardest
thing for me to do in my life has been
to love myself because you know
somewhere in my life and my story or
when I was young or I don't know when
you know I think just because of you
know maybe my you know dad being so old
and you know my mom not feeling like my
mother cared about me or whatever it's
not a sob story I'm not telling you that
but I'm just telling you that I'd never
really loved myself because
I'd never really loved myself because uh
somewhere in my past in like a long time
before that
I guess I you know I just had felt like
I wasn't worth it you know and it's a
it's tough to kind of admit some of that
but uh and it wasn't a choice I made
even like consciously it's not like
somebody said hey are you worth loving
yourself I would have said yes but
somewhere deeper than that like
somewhere when I was young or when I
don't know but just somewhere before
that you know I just decided that I
wasn't you know I just looked at my
surroundings and I don't know I just had
felt or my life or whatever the recipe
was that was in my life I looked at that
and um and I was like oh yeah
yeah you're not you don't deserve or
you're not good or you're bad you're a
bad person or something I don't know
I still don't know you know there's
still a lot for me to learn anyway this
story's a little bit emotional for me
but you know it's this is the story that
I tell and so since I got an in to going
to meetings and stuff like that and look
I wasn't a coke head I have friends that
are Co kids ice cream I mean my coke use
was probably it was over a a couple
years maybe once every few months maybe
three times a year four times a year but
then there was a point over about three
weeks or maybe six weeks I don't know
where it had escalated and it was just
kind of like it was like once a week and
then it was like you know the last two
weeks it was like two or three times a
week you know I mean I'm pissed and I'm
like look I wish I never even got to
smoke crack you know I don't want to be
a crackhead but [ __ ] you know I'll tell
you no I'll take a hit or two just to
see it you know what everybody's talking
about down at the bus at the are down at
the Greyhound you know but since then
you know in this program I've learned
like
you know I've just I don't feel it alone
I I don't feel as alone as I used to and
I'm learning to have different feelings
about myself and different ways to think
about myself and it's a program of
action though like I have to work and I
have to let go to you know some of these
meetings and I go to the meetings man
it's so funny that God used or my higher
power people say higher power God
whatever you know I believe in God I
believe in God you know it's so much out
here in like this business I mean they
try to like make you feel like you it's
not cool to do that but I'm not gonna
feel that way for me because I need that
you know in the program too that you
know the a a it's cool because they it's
not about the drugs and alcohol man you
know I never liked drinking I know I was
never you know I was never a pothead I
was never I just started to see like oh
man
if you to ask me one day will you go to
this great opportunity you have on this
radio station with you know one of the
biggest radio stations that radio shows
in the world would you go on that [ __ ]
up how to said no way and then here I
was doing something that I wouldn't have
done so that's when I realized like you
know I just wasn't I wasn't even doing
things that I really wanted to be doing
and now my life has gotten better man it
really has and sometimes I only want to
admit that you know there's something
inside of me sometimes that wants to
make me separate from other people you
know there's something that wants to
make me alone because it's part of the
only way that I ever knew how to be
and man it has been a journey
nothing withdrew the drugs are not
called men whatever you know I make it
you know I'm a I don't know if I'll
always be sober I have no idea but the
thing that keeps me involved is man I
get I get to learn so much about myself
about loving others about acceptance
it's introduced me to other issues that
I have that you know maybe drugs and
alcohol and even my issue it's just
introduced me into a world of like
introspection like for the first time I
can take a look at myself and uh and I
still look I got a ton of faults I'm not
but I know that if I stay like on this
path that things can get better I
believe that because there's proof for
me you know my career has gotten better
you know I've met people that have loved
me you know I've been I've been in and
out of a relationship with somebody that
loved me you know and for one of the
first times in my life that I really
felt that not that other people hadn't
loved me in the past but this was the
first time I could feel it you know and
it's just because something had changed
inside of me
where
you know where I didn't need to just
have all these walls up or whatever to
survive anymore like you know I think my
higher power wants to tell me look man
you're going to be okay you know you can
take a break
you know and uh anyway you know I don't
know um you know I don't know if I'll
always be a part of this program or not
but you know for the first time I
lifelike this story like that's a you
know I can tell you a true story you
know all the years of like having a line
like you know be ashamed of who I was or
what I was or anything or anything like
that like it's still okay to tell so
he's okay to create and be you know I
want to bring people together and and be
a storyteller and think about things and
that's all okay but for the first time I
life I have a little bit of a story of
my own you know and there are moments
you know not always but there's moments
ronald feels ashamed of myself as i did
for so long man you know I was so
ashamed I was so ashamed of myself for
things I didn't even nothing really for
nothing just because at a young age
nobody had told me not to be ashamed of
myself
you know nobody had told me hey man
you're OK
you know nobody had told me hey man you
are okay and you're not a bad person so
and that's what that's what keeps me
coming back to these programs man the
[ __ ] is lit and it's fun man and every
time I go I get to hear a story that
makes me feel it makes you realize that
I have a heart and then I'm a loving
person because for so much my life I
wanted to know that about myself and now
I go into these rooms and I hear other
people's stories and him and I feel a
certain way in it and there is proof
right there inside of me living inside
of my body through feeling and through
love and that's dope man - it is [ __ ]
dope and so that's kind of where I'm at
man I would um it's 11 p.m. now here on
and I had some calls man look I want to
play one or two calls that came in and
I'm sorry look you know I'm not sorry
about my story but I'm sorry you know I
had a headache I didn't want to tell
that story tonight um because I wanted
to be able to tell it best as I could
and it's hard to think sometime when
your head is hurting you know but you
know my relationships have gotten better
these days you know my brother and I
mean he's so close to my brother these
days like it's uh you know it's wild you
know and you know and I've met like a
couple of the greatest people I've ever
met like through AAA you know I've
learned about like unconditional love
and things like that not things that I'm
able to practice yet but at least for
the first time in my life you know I
mean I'm aware of some of these things
and and more will be revealed man that's
what they say in that program more will
be revealed you know and you can develop
a relationship with a higher power where
you can do what you want
they got coffee they got shitty cookies
you know it's a [ __ ] trap house but
where people get together to share good
time real time and then look it's just
like the comedy club this weekend man
there you could in one room you could
you probably could have bought a gram in
there but in that other room dude we
made some damn magic this weekend but we
lit that [ __ ]
on fire and I am I'm grateful to
everybody that came out it's the
holidays you know I'm so excited man I
get to go home you know I mean I have a
family I have like I got five nieces and
nephews today that love me you know and
even if they don't I get to watch like
my siblings be parents you know I get to
watch my siblings love their children in
a way that we never got to experience
and I'm awake for that
and uh and that's cool man
that for me man this [ __ ] is up this
[ __ ] is a ride bro this [ __ ] is a ride
so I know this [ __ ] got a little bit emo
on this episode and I know it looks like
I'm interrogated this is not an intent
this is not an Isis interrogation video
if you look it on YouTube it really
looks like a trap house but um but you
know I feel you know and I don't
sometimes they say you know you're not
supposed to talk about sobriety in a
public forum and stuff like that but
whatever man you know I've never been
somebody to break it up follow really
the rules I don't think sometimes that's
good and sometimes that's bad but I'm so
grateful everybody that came out this
weekend because they changed my
experience you know on Thursday I was
kind of stressed out Friday I was like
oh this place and by the end I was like
man it doesn't matter where we are you
know at our shows we have a good time
and we do it as you know at a fair price
and uh and I'm grateful man I'm grateful
to the group of people that I get to be
a part of now even in my own shows you
know at our shows we get to do that and
I feel like we're gonna do a lot of cool
stuff in the coming year to help others
and and I just appreciate it man you
know what's interesting too for me is
like this podcast a lot of times even
over the year like maybe there was a
time or two on what I thought on a
Saturday night man I'm gonna get [ __ ]
up you know but then I had to be here
for this podcast on Sunday and so you
know I don't know maybe you know you
guys kept me out of the dark sometimes
here and there and again if your party
and you drink and you getting [ __ ] up
if I'm at your house you're doing coke I
don't care that's fine
if y'all shooting up I'm leaving run
okay if you needle in if you [ __ ]
wrote haystack on your arm and you
[ __ ] needle in yourself I'm out daddy
but if you guys you know your cousin's
on [ __ ] nine tylenol and y'all
blowing a blunt and the G Raja brah I'm
fine you know I don't care if you drink
I don't care if you [ __ ] you know
pour meth down your [ __ ] stepdads you
Asaf a gas that's okay you can do with
that you don't have to adjust in your
life for me anything like that people
need be there's nothing you have to be
weird around these kind of people you
know my biggest problem I realized it
wasn't with drugs or alcohol my biggest
problem was with the way that I felt and
I am relieved of some of that and I'm
learning more all the time man and
that's where I'm at you know that's
where I'm at and I'm so thankful that in
a weird way like all those times of
storytelling in line to people and just
you know I just wanted to feel seemed
okay to them you know you know make the
line about you know where my dad was or
who he was or you know lying about while
I was walking through somebody's
neighborhood after school because I
didn't even live in that neighborhood
you know and just uh just all kind of
stuff man you know it's interesting
because all that time a storytelling now
you know the things that uh that didn't
serve me before now it serves me now I'm
able to go to a place and say you know
and share stories so I mean I think you
know God works in mysterious ways man
and also in unlisted
my [ __ ] mysterious ways but thank you
guys so much for being here with me this
weekend I'm gonna take one one call man
because you know a lot of calls of
coming about this over the years and I
want to do an episode about people that
have been involved but I want to hear
this guy's call oh here we go what's up
Sam thanks for calling in New Jersey I
did a show up there in a Holiday Inn and
a Holiday Inn on if you ever am I got
snot nose like a dang child if holiday
if you ever been a Holiday Inn or not
but it is a I mean it used to be nice
and now it's not but it smells like
chlorine sometimes in the lobby or it
used to homework
for someone who's considering or making
attempts to get sober as well stop
drinking any tips like when you first
started out especially dealing with
social situation is how you keep
yourself you know straight and narrow
word up man I'll tell you for me dude uh
yeah it's up to you if you think you're
sober you're not sober that's your call
only you know I can't tell you if you
are not I can't take if you need to be I
don't know if I'll always be I might
leave off this video screen and go gram
up out on the street son it's Christmas
bro you know it's snow time dude I might
you know hang up down side from a tree
and catch a couple of flakes up my snout
but I might not you know what man I just
kind of embraced it a little bit I told
people in the beginning I just don't
drink I'm taking a break
bah bah blah and then in my line of work
man some of my favorite comedians do not
drink they do not if I mean like you
know y'all know Chris D'Elia my arch
nemesis and he done he's never had a
drop of anything some of the greats you
know and right now in my life is just
like you know it's okay for me to kind
of say that and also if you get into a a
there's so many other people that do not
drink it's crazy
you don't realize it so anyway so that's
that man you know I don't think I'm cool
because it because of AAA or anything
like that but I don't think I'm not cool
because of being sober all right let's
hear another call the great what's up
Greg and Greg is almost spelled the same
backwards and forwards onward okay gang
gang brother thank you man
congratulations dude
I will say that congratulations a year
doing anything I find is really awesome
if you tell yourself you're gonna read
part of a book every day for a year
but if you're gonna take a break from
drugs and alcohol for a year
onward man I want to hear you I want to
hear more from you enough from me
gratulations right it's just crazy to me
that how hard it is but how rewarding it
was and how much you and everybody's
helped me through this and made this
year the best year in my life I honestly
I just want to call and say thank you
for all you've done for me and I know
you don't take compliments well but I
got to give them where to do I just want
to say I appreciate you and everybody
else really give me through what was the
toughest thing to do my life now is what
them now is what really the most
rewarding for me so I just want to call
and say thank you alright man easy on
them out there gang gang gang gang man
and you're welcome man it's funny I
don't take compliments well I don't even
know why that's the case sometimes but I
learned the other day at a meeting if
somebody says something just say is my
pleasure and uh and thank you for that
call cuz that makes me so excited bruh
you know just to hear that it's cool
dude it's just cool that make me excited
cuz I didn't do anything as you did that
but to hear you feel excited about
yourself and to know that maybe for a
long time of your life you didn't feel
that way and now you you can voice that
even feel good about yourself I can
relate to that man I can relate to that
at such a level that man you just made
me feel really really good so thank you
brother I appreciate it we'll get some
other calls next week because we still
got to edit this cat and put it up man
this might be the emo Nemo - I don't
know we got into it tonight you know
some people will add me and say - you
shouldn't talk about sobriety and AAA
and stuff like that are in a public
forum but maybe I'm [ __ ] up you know
you know I don't know but I I think at
least for my listeners you at least kind
of have an idea now and I don't need
people you know asking me hey man you
still you know I don't need I don't need
a DA I don't need anybody check I don't
need anything like that
I don't need um you know I don't need
anything special I don't need any
special treatment I'm fine
you know so you know I don't want you
you know some of them people hear the
word sobering to think it's this crazy
thing it's not a crazy thing I wasn't
ever in you know but there's a lot of
people that struggle and uh and if you
meet one of them you know at least now
you have an idea that sometimes it had
nothing to do with what's going on
outside sometimes it's a lot of thing
that's going on on the inside but inside
and outside so grateful for this podcast
and for you guys coming out this weekend
we sold them out they're sold out in
Lexington this coming weekend we're sold
out in addison man i am fortunate to
have so to be able to meet so many neat
people so looking forward to it we'll
see you guys next time and we'll leave
out on that uh boys Bishop Gunn who are
actually in town tonight I just found
out they're in town tonight here in uh
in Los and uh in Washington DC but I
just got a text from burn a few minutes
ago the drummer yeah they're in town I
don't think I'm gonna be able to see
them but um well at least we can listen
to them right here together but if
you're in Washington DC if you don't
have tickets for them I think they're
here on Tuesday or something they said
they're performing or Wednesday maybe
have a great week
be good to yourselves and have a happy
holiday season man and if you're still
out there drinking man drink up you feel
me drank the fog up son have one for
pop-pop-pop-pop Gang Gang man you guys
be good yourselves you deserve it man I
knew it I absolutely know it
[Music]
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could I be so far
and my mind is somewhere else but when I
found it I'll patch up where it's been
[Music]
just floating on the breeze and I feel
like these must be Cornerstone thank you
guys man for being here happy holidays
Merry Christmas
me too said that parking brake and let
my cell phone
me I'll sit and tell you my story
no me
[Music]
just oh you spiked the punch baby
man I'm so excited to go to New Orleans
dude all my friends and family are gonna
be there
my sister has mold in her house
[ __ ] yeah son let's do it
thank you guys man
shine a lot on me
[Music]
me singing just for you
[Music]
I'll sit and tell you my story
and that is huh [ __ ] it
Oh